IM PUTIN'S ON IS TWO WEEKS OLMA
PUSHED PUTINS
ECONOMY.
LITTLEONAPRESSURING THE
PRESIDT WILL DETER HIM. ISOLATE
MOREELY HE I
EURASIA GROUP.OR YOUR TIME TODA
OF, RDHEANS,
A A MATERNITWARD IN MARIUPOL
THINAN HAVE
YOU HAVE STUDIED VLADIMIR PUTI
EOPLMIGHT  THIS, MORE
INDISCRIMINATE ATTACKS ON  AREA
ATHOTIN D UP IN
OWN DOME POLIC
ENVIRONMENT, CERTAINLY IN TERMS
SECURITY ENVIRONMENT WHICHN HE I
UKRAINE TO BEGIN WH, HE WILLOF
BEFORE HE INVADE
ITR Y FO
CLIMB DOWAT THE NT TS PEOPLE I
ACCOMPLISHED XD Z.W  THE. IS KE
IMAG FROM
BUT RIGHT NOW I DON'NDTHUNDEARYR
PEOPLEILL HAVE TAS PUT TAING ATN
CHANGE COURSE OR THEAN
TTHEIROWN OT THE PX, IF YOU WILN
ARE GOINOR.
ECONOM STANDPOINT.
HE HASHE OOST WANTO TROOPS, , AO
A CARSON WOULD
STA DOWN.
OPPOSITE. UTINE
>> VNULAND'S POINT FRON PERSIVE
THAT'S WTHLLANS ARE DOING IS TH
HEREE RUSSIANSEA
D TO, R ATTA WE NEED TO NDWAYS U
IT'S NOTOI TO BENOH US TO JUST I
UNDERSNDWEANTHE
UNCONSAB
IN APENDENT COUNTRY OF44 MILLIO
E S ACTS OEY ARE IN
POSITION TO LIATE.  PUTIN EN
YESTERDAY.
AC S IS AN TSSIAN
WOULD LIKE  E MOTHS, WIVESSTS,
SOLDIERS AND OFFICERS WHO
SSIA DG ECL MILITARY
OPERATION.
I UNDERS H A
YOUR LOVED ONES.
CAN BE
JUST AS THE WHOLY PROUD OF THED
THEM TOGETHE YOU.
LET MESIZE THAT MILITARYTSD WIL
PARTICIPATLITIESE WILL BE NO AD
CALL-UPS OF RESERV F
KNOWRECONSCRIPTS IN UKRAINE  TIR
YY SIGNIFICINTO THE
COMPELLED TODD
NVISION?
, ANTHE FACTS
THEY'RE NOT JUST CASUAS
CASUALTIES IN THG BROTHER AND S.
OF RAN
WILL FEEL UNCOMFORTABLE
DON'T KN W FOR
WHEN IT'S RUSSIAN NSUKRAN. TO R
W HAS BECOMN
WAY THE INFORMATION WAR
WORLD, P IS WINNING IT
RUA MAJORITY OF RUSSIANSHATHE UK
ACT GENOCIDE
AGAI IN OC
RUSSIANS ARE FORCED INTOWAR USG
ACTIONS BY THEKRAINIANS AND
NATO AND I
ALMYS
CRIPPLED, THEY BLAMEFO
THN.